you might have heard that australian
sunscreens are the best in the world and
here's why sunscreens the ones you use
for sun protection anyway are regulated
as drugs here which means that there are
stricter rules on how they're made we
also have the strictest water resistance
rules an spf 50 sunscreen with 4 hours
water resistance means it was tested to
stay at spf 50 after 4 hours in water in
europe it can drop down to spf 25 and
still be labeled as spf 50. the us also
has sunscreens as drugs and the same
water resistance rule but their standard
for broad spectrum is lower in australia
and the eu sunscreens have to pass two
tests to get the broad spectrum rating
which means there's lots of uva
protection sunscreens in the us only
have to pass one test some sunscreens
that are broad spectrum in the us
wouldn't be broad spectrum in australia
and the eu australia also forces
sunscreens above a certain spf to be
broad spectrum so you're covered even if
you forget to check for broad spectrum
basically australia took the best parts
of sunscreen regulation from every other
country and just smoosh them together